sing it if you know the word so this is
Hans camp
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
in honor of Rihanna doing the halftime
show pregnant I will be performing with
five days worth of semen saved up in my
body
thank you
um you know my friend was bragging about
working at a PR firm he's like I'll work
at a PR firm I was like no one cares
that you work in Puerto Rico
let me know what you got a job at a USA
firm
yeah doing pretty good
I think
I saw a group of blind people walking
around
I was like how do they meet
just bump into each other once and
remember the footsteps
my friend was like dude stop staring at
them
it's like why
foreign
thank you
did you say blind people yeah how dare
you with deep Madness six feet behind
you make fun of
I love the blind uh but
I did see a group of Middle Eastern
blind people walking around I was like
whoa I need to write a joke
with the
were they really uh how do you know they
were Middle Eastern uh you could tell
uh
they're kind of hairy and like the
Middle Eastern spots of their face
Middle Eastern spots on their face yeah
okay what are those uh just like a heavy
beard uh you know just like some weird
thing going on with their head scarves
oh scarves yeah it was it was really
concerning from a like security
standpoint
if only those
and they've got a couple of strikes
against them
if only those were the pilots that tried
to fly into the World Trade Center it
would have
ended up
747s end up in the Atlantic Ocean today
stunning turn of events
[Music]
every flight would have been United 93
on that day
blind Middle Eastern people what else
has been going on in your life Hans what
have you been up to I recently went to
Rochester and instead of taking a
feature I just took a beautiful Jew
and we had sex 17 times okay you might
need to make it more clear for people
that the beautiful Jew that you're
talking about is your girlfriend yes
so instead of taking an opening act you
decided to take your girlfriend yes how
were the opening acts was it worth it
they were great thank you for showing up
oh you're pandering to two people you'll
never see again in Rochester right you
have to jump in on the Jew part
that what
that watch girlfriend she's so amazing
like how she's like
[Laughter]
she's like she's really good at Mental
Math she's really good at figuring out
how much the tip should be
usually zero
that is true Tim Dylan you've watched
hans's rise uh yes and what do you think
about tonight's appearance what I loved
about it was one Asian guy in the crowd
did a black power salute
two Hans
I don't know what that means I think it
means stop Asian hate is over
and everyone's good now so that's
something I enjoyed watching
I love it uh Hans you get the show
started every week I love it we're gonna
keep it moving quickly this week get
some names out of the bucket thank you
so much thank you everybody uh what the
format of the show is like and like that
things get wild